one of the things that has begun to
worry me is the fact that I'm seeing
change happening at a scale which was
unimaginable before and that is
impacting industry after industry after
industry every industry have looked at
I've seen a trend of major disruption
happening manufacturing is the most
obvious there with robotics and 3d
printing as this year it is cheaper to
manufacture in the United States than it
is in China it is cheaper to manufacture
in Europe than it is in China why is
that because with automated robots that
have two arms that have screens which
show you the emotion with the sensors
they have around them I'm talking about
Baxter from the rethink robotics or
Universal these robots have become very
sophisticated the cost of operation is
less than the cost of human labor so we
can now have robots working 24/7 doing
the things that human beings did give it
five years these robots will become ever
more sophisticated they'll be doing many
many more jobs which means that the
manufacturing industry is going to be
disrupted in a very big way
the good news for America is that it's
coming back here the good news for
Europe is it's coming back there the
good news for Asia is that it's also
going to become a local industry bad
news for China because it's no longer no
longer to happen in China so by the end
of the decade you're going to see major
upheaval and manufacturing opportunities
and problems move into the next decade
these men these robots will probably go
on strike because we won't need them
anymore we'll have 3d printers now
within fifteen to twenty years we will
be able to 3d print electronics sin
Majan being able to design your own
iPhone and and print it at home that is
what becomes technically feasible in the
in the 15 to 20 year time frame so
you're talking about major disruption
happening to manufacturing in the short
term and then even greater to disruption
happening in the long term now look at
finance we're seeing the turmoil that
Bitcoin is Kreuger is creating you now
have many parties supporting it well you
also have crowdfunding shaking up the
venture capital industry that they
become less relevant will soon have
crowd funding for loans that in some
countries already the experimenting with
with taking out loans by
you want to buy a house you want to buy
a car you simply get it from a large
number of people you're now moving into
godless transactions for purchasing
goods we may not need the banks anymore
we may not need financial institutions
the way we do right now so so there's
going to have made this weapon happen
different actual services whether or not
financial services wield it realizes it
in the USA they seem to be complacent
because they've got laws protecting them
but the same laws don't apply in other
countries we may well have major
innovations happening abroad which come
to you to the United States look at
health care that already we now have
apples putting a stake in the ground
saying we're going to be the platform
for health they basically have announced
a health platform what they want is that
all of these new sensor devices that
have become in common which monitor your
your blood pressure which monitor your
blood oxygenation
we've monitor your heartbeats which
monitor your temperature which monitor
your activity levels and soon which will
monitor your blood glucose and monitor
you know your internals they want all of
these data being uploaded to the Apple
platform do you think Google Google will
be left behind do you think Microsoft
will be left behind do you think Samsung
will be left behind everyone is jumping
into the act
but soon when you have all of these data
we were able to be able to be able to
transform the healthcare industry
because we will be able to predict when
someone is about to get sick we will
have AI based physicians they can advise
us when we're about to get sick that can
advise us on what we need to do to get
healthy when you say the problem that
doctors have right now is that the data
that I get back from medical tests is so
complicated that they can't they can
often not understand it especially in
fields like cancer if you look at the
reports and I've seen some of these
reports they're incredibly complex add
to it the genomics area we're going to
be getting the cost of human genome
sequencing is dropped to $1,000 over the
last 15 years at the rated which by
going the cost of sequencing will be
practically zero with so which means
that we'll all have genomes done you
combine that with the medical sensor
data combine that with the radio VM in
the cloud you've got a healthcare
revolution revolution we won't need
doctors for day-to-day medical advice
anymore we'll have robotic surgeons
doing sophisticated surgery so we're
going to
the medical profession we're going to
now upend the entire healthcare system
there we know it all in the next five to
ten years people don't seem to
understand this now look at the energy
industry
we're fighting wars over oil we five
years ago we worried about America
running out of oil today we're talking
about Saudi America because of fracking
fracking is a harmful technology
nevertheless it is allowed America to
become energy independent and soon to
become an energy exporter forget about
fracking solar itself is something we've
become negative about but solar has
dropped about ninety seven point two
percent over the past 35 years in price
at the rate which solar is advancing by
the end of this decade we achieve great
battery in the United States great
vitamin is cheaper to produce energy at
home on your solar cells then buy it
from the grid move forward another ten
years it costs you one hundred says much
to to produce your own solar your own
energy than to buy from the grid which
means that we have these grid companies
now in serious trouble this is why you
have the utilities fighting solar that
they're now started opposing solar
subsidies they've now doing everything
they can to stop the solar industry
because on its own solar if it keeps
advancing the way it will and there's
every indication that it will it's going
to eclipse the fossil fuel industry and
solar is one of maybe a hundred
technologies that are advancing which
will change the energy industry so now
you have unlimited energy well guess
what we have unlimited clean water
because we can simply boil as much what
as we want we have unlimited water we
can now have vertical farms in which we
grow food locally imagine now having
100% organic food where you don't have
to have you have insecticides and so on
pumped into it because you have it
produced in sealed buildings in in in
vertical farms imagine now being able to
3d print meat so we don't have to
slaughter animals so we're talking about
a pending agriculture and the entire
food production industry so I can go on
and on and on every industry I've looked
at I've seen major disruption even even
good old communications you look at the
impact AT&T Verizon and Sprint will
suffer over the next decade or so
they've seen the landline business
disappear landlines when
to mobile and then now we have data I
mean when I travel abroad right now I
don't make long-distance calls anymore
because I just call it a Skype imagine
when we have Wi-Fi everywhere AT&T and
and Google are competing now to do wire
up regions with superfast internet
access what happens now when you have
open networks everywhere so you can make
phone calls over Wi-Fi networks we're
talking about disrupting the
communications industry I can go on and
on and on but every industry I look at I
see major disruption happening so the
world 10 to 15 to 20 years from now is
going to be completely different we're
going to be disrupting industry after
industry after industry the vast
majority of companies who are the
leaders right now may not even exist
because the problem is that not only are
people not aware of it most industry
executives dare not invest adapt of
money that will be required for them to
reinvent themselves they they're not put
themselves out of business so major
disruption this company is coming our
industry heads are worried about
short-term performance they dare not see
that this future we headed into so
they're going to be disrupted we will
have new industries coming out of
nowhere
eclipsing these these online industries
new trillion-dollar industries wiping on
existing trillion-dollar industries this
is a future where adventure for better
or for worse